bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce mercredi 17 février avec la
crise sanitaire la précarité des
étudiants s'est accentuée près de 20%
d'entre eux vivraient sous le seuil de
pauvreté en france depuis janvier en
conséquence les restaurants
universitaires propose des repas un euro
emmanuel macron a de son côté fait
également d'autres annonces en faveur de
la jeunesse nous en parlons avec notre
invité béatrice piron député des
yvelines
il avait bénéficié du premier programme
de renouvellement urbain le quartier des
musiciens aux mureaux va continuer sa
rénovation sept ans de travaux avec au
programme des démolitions et des
réhabilitations de logements
l objectif être intégré dans un futur
écoquartier et puis en ce début des
vacances d'hiver pourquoi ne pas aller
piquer une tête qu'en plein air dans une
eau à 27° la piscine intercommunale de
saint germain en laye vient d'ouvrir son
bassin extérieur l agence régionale de
santé la préfecture des yvelines ont
donné leur autorisation après avoir
validé le protocole sanitaire et puis
reportage dans ce journal à plaisir dans
le restaurant la maison des bois qui a
rouvert depuis un mois après un incendie
s'était liner l'année dernière en 2020
les restaurants universitaires ont donc
lancé les repas à 1 euro pour tous les
étudiants depuis janvier auparavant
seuls les étudiants boursiers pouvaient
bénéficier de ce dispositif m haies la
crise sanitaire a exacerbé la précarité
chez les jeunes exemple aussi de vauban
à guyancourt avec célia gars de son goût
un euro symbolique voilà le prix d'un
repas à emporter dans le restaurant
universitaire vauban de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
un repas qui un coût complet de 7 euros
70 est vendu 1 euro
donc c'est un marqueur très fort
vis-à-vis du monde étudiant depuis le 8
février les étudiants peuvent consommer
maintenant leurs plats à emporter chaud
sur place avec un protocole strict de
mètres carrés entre chaque personne
aucun étudiant face à face et un
nettoyage des tables régulier les
étudiants ont aussi la possibilité de
prendre en plus un repas froid pour le
soir à réchauffer au micro ondes
on sentait que les étudiants on avait
besoin et j'ai régulièrement mois des
mails me demandant comment ils peuvent
déjeuner sur quel site et donc on leur
répond instantanément pour qu'il puisse
bénéficier de ce repas vendredi 12
février ils étaient plus de 200
étudiants à prendre un repas le midi et
près d'une cinquantaine ont acheté
également un plat pour le soir je trouve
que ça permet de rendre plus accessible
le repas il ya beaucoup plus d'étudiants
j'ai l'impression qu'ils viennent le
midi et donc c'est plutôt une bonne
chose s'il n'a pas l'air pas un euro aux
vaches mangent pas de la journée en fait
ou alors je me tape une salade sodebo à
3 euros carrefour mais je peux pas le
faire de faute
donc
on se plaint parfois du crous mais là
sur ce coup là ils nous prennent bien en
charge
non c'est une bonne idée je trouve ça
très pratique parce que bon moi j'ai une
bourse donc évidemment ça va aller mais
je pense que déjà les premières pas à
3h30 c'était déjà pas mal et maintenant
on est passé à 1 euro c'est la moindre
des choses que je pense donc moi je
ressens très bien depuis 15 jours quatre
fois plus d'étudiants sont venus manger
dans ce restaurant universitaire et pour
parler de ce sujet de la précarité
étudiante et de l'action de la majorité
présidentielle pour l'endiguer je reçois
un plateau béatrice piron bonsoir
bonsoir député la république en marge de
la 3ème circonscription des yvelines
alors sert pas un euro ont été premiers
par emmanuel macron lors de son
déplacement à l'université paris saclay
c'était en janvier
cette mise en place et est urgente dans
ce contexte de crise sanitaire et où 20%
des étudiants vivrait aujourd'hui sous
le seuil de pauvreté
mais oui c'était étaient nécessaires
c'était déjà en place depuis le mois de
septembre pour tous les étudiants
boursiers
donc ça a été étendue à tous les
étudiants sans justificatifs donc depuis
depuis le 21 janvier
ils étaient peu présents jusqu'à présent
dans les universités mais elle ré ouvre
aussi petit à petit aujourd'hui donc
normalement tous les étudiants des
quelques cours par semaine donc en
présentiel avec une jauge maximum
nasillarde ce qui est de 20% si oui est
ce qui fait que petit à petit les
étudiants retournent donc dans les
restaurants universitaires et j'ai
changé je vais interroger donc le crous
des yvelines donc et aujourd'hui c'est
2500 repas qui ont été servis ces dix
derniers jours donc dans les restaurants
universitaires des ibériques salue le
fait que ça puisse être étendue à
l'ensemble des étudiants ça a été permis
par le doublement du budget du crous
avait été annoncée par le premier
ministre en novembre dernier un budget
qui est passé à 56 millions d'euros dé
en hausse oui oui donc il ya eu une
amélioration donc sur le crous local je
ne sais pas exactement au niveau
national c'est plus 135 millions d'euros
qui ont été accordés donc pour dominer
justement en prévoyance en prévision de
cette difficulté qu'on présentait
justement vous disiez dans les yvelines
ce a démarré doucement est ce que
aujourd'hui c'est bien en place serpa un
euro est ce qu'ils sont alors les
emplois encore constater par moi-même
j'ai pris rendez vous lundi donc lundi
j'irai donc à guyancourt donc au
restaurant vauban pour pouvoir comment
ça se déroule mais à d'après les
informations que j'ai eu à la fois de
l'université et du cros oui ça semble
bien fonctionner
au départ il y avait une cinquantaine
d'étudiants et maintenant il ya plus de
200 étudiants donc à lui en cours qui se
déplacent pour venir chercher leur
panier
ce que je vous pose cette question alors
au niveau national il ne s'agit pas d'un
cas dans les yvelines hier l'émission
quotidien était dans une file d'attenté
d'un restaurant universitaire parisien
est révélé que parmi les cinq cents 500
étudiants qui attendaient aucun n'avait
pu accéder à ces repas à 1 euro pourtant
premier par le président de la
république ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
encore peut-être certains
dysfonctionnements aujourd'hui d'ajuster
avec le jeu n'est pas je n'ai pas eu
d'informations précises sur ce cas
particulier mais a visiblement c'était
hier soir ce qui est surprenant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les restaurants
universitaires avec le couvre feu de 18h
au fond plutôt le midi alors est ce
qu'il y avait eu une annonce
exceptionnelle d'ouverture le soir je ne
sais pas dans les yvelines s'est fermé
le soir c'est uniquement le midi et on
emporte son repas du soir
il s'agit d'un cas effectivement à paris
d'autres annonces du président de la
république alors là on va au delà de la
précarité étudiante qui est aussi la
question du lien social qui a été
évoquée vous parliez tout à l'heure de
cette réouverture pour 20% des étudiants
de la réouverture des universités pour
20 % de leurs effectifs étudiants c'est
ça on parle souvent de précarité il ya
aussi le lien social à côté à ne pas
négliger c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya
une une réouverture permettre aux
étudiants de pouvoir revenir même un
jour à l'université par semaine alors ça
paraissait indispensable pour les aider
à mieux appréhender donc
leur étude va pouvoir poser des
questions voir leurs camarades et voir
le professeur et on a bien conscience
qu'aujourd'hui l'isolément et le fait de
supprimer toutes les activités extra
étude on va dire tous les sorties tous
les cinémas toutes les soirées
étudiantes c'est carrément général le
camp quand on fait des études d'aller à
des soirées donc sa baisse le moral des
étudiants aujourd'hui donc on a des
numéros de téléphone des appels
téléphoniques et les étudiants peuvent
aussi consulter les psychologues s'ils
se sentent en détresse il ya également
des étudiants tuteurs qui essayent de
détecter les cas difficiles qu'on veut
évidemment éviter ces des situations
dramatiques
on va parler du chèque psy qui a été
aussi mise en place est ce que
aujourd'hui voir un retour peut-être
d'ici la fin de l'année universitaire
d'un retour à la normale à l'université
de 100 % des étudiants est ce que ça
vous paraît utopique au vu du contexte
sanitaire pas avant le mois de juin
c'est sûr que c'est notamment est
possible sur à la rentrée prochaine donc
à l'automne prochain si tout le monde
est vacciné qu'on arrive à l'axé tout le
monde on espère fortement de pouvoir
tous revenir mais aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune certitude qu'il faut se préparer
petit à petit mais ce qu'il faut faire
c'est le maximum que l'on peut toujours
donc on est sur une ligne de crête
on essaye d'amener le plus possible
d'étudier en présentiel c'est pas
toujours facile parce que quand vous
avez que deux heures de présentiel dans
la journée c'est difficile quand on
habite loin de l'université de ses
passes et uniquement pour deux heures de
cours donc les cours sont pas
obligatoires sont pas pénalisés s'ils
sont pas présents ils sont souvent en
hybride avec une possibilité à 2,1 à
distance ou en présentiel ce sont les
étudiants qui choisissent
mais petit à petit quand même il ya un
retour vers les universités c'est
évident il y avait aussi cette annonce
donc du coup sûr la précarité étudiante
sur le parcours de soins plus
précisément avec la mise en place d'un
chèque psy autrement dit financer des
consultations de psychologie en
psychologie pour les étudiants il
fallait pas aussi oublier ce volet là le
volet psychologique on sait que la crise
sanitaire a un impact psychologique pas
que sur les étudiants d'ailleurs mais il
ya aussi cette cette problématique
tout à fait donc il y avait déjà des
psychologues au sein du service de santé
universitaire donc à l'université de
saint quentin
donc il y avait 2,2 psycholoque et qui
était déjà habituellement présents il y
en a eu un troisième poste qui a été
ouvert
donc été pourvus donc qui financé par le
ministère il ya un quatrième poste qui
en cours d'étude plus la possibilité
donc de consulter chez des psychologues
libéraux donc sa fonction déjà
aujourd'hui donc trois ya possibilité
même à travers d'autolib de prendre
rendez-vous de téléconsultation
psychologie qui sera pris en charge à
100% donc avec ces chèques étudiants une
dernière chose béatrice pire en novembre
dernier jean castex avait promis aussi
la création de vingt mille job étudiant
est ce que c'est ces emplois ont été
créés au aujourd'hui où est-ce que ils
doivent être encore créé sur
l'université saint quentin il ya déjà eu
beaucoup de postes donc une 50
une vingtaine de postes donc
d'ambassadeur médiateur donc qu vide qui
sont des étudiants dont qui permettent
de rappeler et d'expliquer les gestes
barrières et qui permet de détecter les
étudiants qui seraient en difficulté ou
en détresse
et il ya en courbe un temps de réflexion
et de recrutement de 58 heures
supplémentaires pourquoi là d'un point
de vue donc enseignement aider les
étudiants surtout de premier et de
deuxième année et par des étudiants de
3e ou 4e année cinquième année donc il y
à qui on a proposé des emplois à temps
partiel donc pouvoir coacher des plus
jeunes et il n'y a pas que au sein
d'universités on essaye justement de
créer des emplois pour ces étudiants qui
ont parfois perdu leur petit job à côté
donc le département aussi contribue donc
il ya des programmes us qui
habituellement tourné que l'été qui est
maintenue maintenant toute l'année pour
accompagner des seniors donc ça permet
d'avoir un emploi pour pour des juniors
il ya de l'aide aux devoirs pour les
jeunes enfants de des services sociaux
dont qui a été proposé et donc le
département on en discute aujourd'hui
donc par rapport à cette précarité des
étudiants vont ils vont essayer de
monter quelques emplois aussi au niveau
des restos du coeur pour pouvoir aider
donc à faire après la grosse collecte
nationale de début mars donc on va
pouvoir collecter on espère beaucoup de
denrées sur les yvelines pouvoir aider
au tri donc c'est aux étudiants pour en
avoir un emploi à cette pierre à ce
moment là donc c'est déjà créé en tout
cas c'est en place et ça va être
renforcée dans les yvelines merci
béatrice piron d'avoir été avec nous
mais je remercie député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines
dans l'actualité politique les élections
départementales et régionales
officiellement en reporter de mars à
juin prochain le parlement a entériné
cette décision après un ultime vote à
main levée au sénat les députés
l'avaient approuvé mardi dans l'après
midi le projet de loi avait fait l'objet
d'un accord entre les deux chambres
après une commission mixte paritaire le
texte en revanche ne fixe pas les dates
précises des deux scrutins
le gouvernement a réaffirmé de son côté
sa volonté d'organiser les élections les
13 et 20 juin au mur au quartier des
musiciens ce quartier va être rénové des
travaux qui s'inscrivent dans la
continuité du premier programme de
renouvellement urbain mené dans la ville
pour cette deuxième phase de rénovation
plusieurs acteurs vont intervenir le
bailleur les résidences yvelines essonne
le conseil régional le département la
ville ou encore la communauté urbaine
gps et au les précisions de justin
brasier des travaux pour la rénovation
urbaine du quartier des musiciens aux
mureaux
il fera partie d'un ensemble
l'écoquartier molière le quartier des
musiciens intégrera
complètement c'était qu'au quartier et
sera même le point de jonction entre le
parc que molière à qui est la pierre
angulaire verte de l'éco quartier et le
parc de sceaux tour qui situe de l'autre
côté du quartier des musiciens donc le
quartier des musiciens va être au centre
à la jonction de ces deux équipements
verts est donc lui aussi verdir 1 à
cette occasion
objectif pour le bailleur les résidences
yvelines essonne réhabiliter la majeure
partie du quartier en plusieurs étapes
environ 196 logements vont être démolis
723 vont être réhabilités la première ça
va être la démolition des trois tours
debussy qui représente 196 logements et
notre seconde intervention c'est la
réhabilitation de l'ensemble de notre
patrimoine restants qui correspond à 723
logements dans le cadre de cette
rénovation le département a lancé un
appel à projets priori blinn c'est un
programme de relance et d'investissement
pour le développement de l'offre
résidentielle
il permet au département d'accompagner
les collectivités qui développe des
projets de rénovation urbaine c'est la
communauté grand paris seine et oise qui
a été sélectionné une candidate et en
2017 ils ont inscrit de mémoire aux
projets secteur maintenir mais qui
concernait tout aussi bien le démon
présidentielle à la main sur ben et des
musiciens faisait partie de cette
candidature au titre de la rénovation
urbaine
le projet va s'échelonner de 2021 à 2028
coût total 110 millions d'euros
à bientôt une réunion à poissy entre
jeunes et forces de l'ordre elles
devraient être organisées dans les
prochains jours à l'initiative de la
mairie le but renouer le dialogue après
les scènes de violences du week-end
dernier une vidéo a été révélé montrant
une patrouille de police sérieusement
prise à partie par une trentaine de
personnes dans le quartier de beauregard
la tension n'est pas retombée hier mardi
des policiers ont essuyé des jets de
cocktails molotov et de pierres rue
saint-exupéry est deux personnes ont été
d'ailleurs interpellé suite à cet
incident d'autres faits de violences
contre les forces de l'ordre ont été
relevés ce mardi à montigny le
bretonneux et à sartrouville
par ailleurs on a appris sur twitter que
la police nationale des yvelines a
procédé avait procédé à 24 verbalisation
hier dans un bar de
voisins-le-bretonneux ces personnes
assistaient
retransmission télévisée d'un match de
football malgré la fermeture imposée en
ce moment et malgré le couvre-feu à 18h
une demande de fermeture administrative
a été également dressé direction plaisir
à présent le restaurant la maison des
bois s'est lancé dans la vente à
emporter un moyen pour les lavernhe le
couple à la tête de l'établissement de
rebondir après la crise sanitaire et
suite à un incendie survenu après le
premier confinement et qui avait ravagé
les lieux
le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet l'année
2020 les a éprouvé mais rien n'arrêtera
le couple lavernhe à la tête du
restaurant familial et gastronomique la
maison des bois
jenny et laurent ont rouvert leurs
établissements il y a seulement un mois
en plus de la crise sanitaire un
incendie a ravagé une partie du
restaurant en juin dernier
ça s'est passé tout simplement un court
circuit dans les combles suite aux
experts des pompiers des assurances on
sortait nu de du premier confinement
donc ça a été très compliqué on va dire
juillet août le temps de trouver les
entreprises on en a profité pour
rebondir
on se dit bon on va aller de l'avant
maintenant
voilà le kobe ne nous a pas eu la
première fois bella sont ni non plus
créé en 1926 est tenu par la même
famille de génération en génération
l' incendie a été un choc mais après de
nombreux travaux pour refaire
l'intégralité de la salle comme le toit
en chaume ou encore remplacer les
historiques poutres apparentes
le couple lavernhe s'est lancé dans la
vente à emporter
on a commencé uniquement la vente
emporté à la fin des travaux suite à
l'incendié du restaurant donc ça ne fait
que maintenant on va faire un mois
vraiment qu'on fait de la vente à
emporter
au début on était un peu timide parce
qu'on voulait surtout contacter les gens
qui l'avaient soutenu après l incendie
puis maintenant ça commence à prendre de
l'ampleur
et on essaye de garder notre qualité
donc on préfère bloquer le nombre donc
faire un gros volume et de l'ampleur il
y en avait le week-end dernier pour la
saint valentin une grosse période pour
la maison des bois
les habitués étaient au rendez vous sur
trois jours plus de 200 commandes ont
été vendus un mot de culture le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a accueilli
la compagnie a les filles du renard pâle
pour son spectacle résiste c'était les
11 et 12 février dernier
si la représentation n'a pu être joué
devant un public les artistes ont pu
tout de même présenter leur travail aux
professionnels justin brasil
depuis le 1er novembre les théâtres
s'organise pour ouvrir leurs portes aux
compagnies pour filmer les spectacles ou
être vu par des professionnels au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15
spectacles ont été maintenus dans ces
conditions objectif que les spectacles
soient vues entre le mois de novembre et
aujourd'hui il ya des 10es les dj dire
des centaines de spectacles qui ont été
créés beaucoup l'on va plus jouer
c'est dans ce cadre que la compagnie les
filles du renard pâle a présenté son
spectacle résiste une représentation
destinée aux professionnels et aux
programmateurs le spectacle de
funambules était à l'origine conçu pour
l'extérieur qui l'accompagné ainsi toute
la semaine le théâtre pour adapter ce
spectacle
pour la salle puisque ni les lumières ni
leçon nous sont exactement le même qu'à
l'extérieur on est vraiment dans des
conditions de jeu très différentes
donc voilà ça fait partie des choses que
l'on arrive à faire pendant se dire ce
confinement mais pendant cette fermeture
des théâtres sur scène un régisseur une
chanteuse et une funambule cette
dernière évolue sur une structure conçue
spécialement pour le spectacle
il a appelé le fil instable donc l'idée
c'est un fils qui se casse la gueule qui
s'incline qui bouge qui va dans tous les
sens l'idée c'est de tenir sur le fil
cool que coûte que coûte quoi qu'il
arrive et de voilà de faire passer aussi
le message de quoi qu'il arrive même si
une fille l'iton bivala qu'il ya plein
de choses qui se passent à 20 de
finalement se réapproprier l'espace tel
qu'il est devenu et puis bah tout ce qui
peut nous arriver dans la gueule
finalement en retirer quelque chose de
positif et puis continuer à se battre
continue à aller de l'avant pendant le
spectacle le fil s'élèvera à 4 m 85 une
petite hauteur pour johan clain il est
il est pas très haut mais il ya pas mal
de techniques donc moi je reste que sur
le fil il n'y a pas de plateforme bâtera
sont à structure ya pas de plate forme
il n'y a rien donc je suis de a à z que
sur le film ou sur le balancier et sinon
après je fais dans les grandes
traversées je peux monter pour l'instant
de planck les fesses et jusqu'à 40
mètres de hauteur et puis sur des
grandes longueurs de 120 mètres de long
plus la compagnie reviendra à saint
quentin en yvelines en septembre pour
retrouver son public
elle présentera une version rue du
spectacle
[Musique]
et puis pendant ces vacances scolaires
aller piquer une tête à la piscine c'est
possible à saint germain en laye où un
bassin extérieur chauffé a ouvert ses
portes la semaine dernière l agence
régionale de santé et la préfecture des
yvelines ont validé le protocole
sanitaire
plongez avec michael et demi d'euros
eléonore sinoquet se baigner dans une
eau à 28° pendant les vacances scolaires
c'est possible à saint gérand les la
piscine a ouvert ce jeudi 11 février un
bassin extérieur il rouverture associé à
un protocole sanitaires strictes validé
par l' agence régionale de santé et la
préfecture des yvelines
on arrive à la cao donc on donne ses
coordonnées
ensuite donc on soit une petite fiche
numérotés et cette petite fiche en fait
elle va suivre va nous suivre du début à
la sortie de l'équipement c'est à dire
que ce numéro on va le retrouver sur
notre cabine de change sur notre casier
de façon à pouvoir angers nos affaires
et puis on est au bord de la piscine
là où on va pouvoir poser nos affaires
également de faire en toute sécurité
la rouverture de ce bassin de 25 m et la
toute première de ce type dans les
yvelines
on se satisfait de la moindre
réouverture j'avais mon collègue de
maisons laffitte qui est là aujourd'hui
j'espère que aussi réfléchi ça arrive
rire leur piscine voilà je crois qu'il
faut il faut être pragmatique qu'il faut
faire preuve de souplesse et dès qu'on
peut ré ouvrir quelque chose il faut le
faire quarante-six personnes peuvent
être accueillies en même temps dans le
bassin depuis sa réouverture la plupart
des créneaux sont complets ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas nager du coup
ça me faisait plaisir de revenir
et j'avais jamais enfin j étais jamais
allé dans la piscine extérieure du coup
c'était très sympa alors ouverture c'est
sympathique ça donne un peu l'impression
aux 10es de bassins un peu suédois
norvégiens avec la fumée et ou par honte
irak est un petit peu de monde donc faut
vraiment trop vraiment nager quoi le
droit d'entrée est à 8 euros aucune
réservation n'est nécessaire la piscine
sera ouverte tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche de 9h30 à 16h30
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant
l'émission 7,8 société est présentée par
mélanie poquet le thème ce soir comment
lutter contre la sédentarité des jeunes
c'est à suivre
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]